alors nous recevons et c'est un grand
plaisir hervé le bras ce soir
vous avez sur la la petite feuille qui
vous a été remise
quelques phrases sur
cet homme de qui depuis quand même
depuis plus de 30 ans
et oui c'est bien ta place
hervé le bras était dans le paysage de
la recherche et le paysage intellectuel
français
n'ont pas du tout un être à part et que
ceux qui quittent qu'il s'active et gay
et qu'il aurait pensé ses idées et ses
résultats de ces recherches une enfin il
est un des très rares qui partent de
de l'ined qui partent de la démographie
je trouve que dans le le concert des
sciences sociales et y compris dans son
utilisation politique possible qu'ils
sont très rares et moi ça m'a toujours
frappé
mais pas seulement être titre
d'historien comment l'argument
démographique
a par rapport à il ya 40 ans a très
largement disparu n'est pas du
raisonnement et même de la programmation
politique des choses l'argument des
grosses masses humaines
internationales et nationales et là
hervé le bras a été de ceux qui ont
obtenu la barre vraiment très très
énergiquement en ayant constamment parce
que c'est son métier ce qu'il aime bien
mal il sort de l'x quelque part n'est ce
pas avec une je dirais une fougue
cartographique tout à fait étonnant il a
sans cesse sans cesse re triturer re
tripoter ces modélisations et c
et ça donne je dirais une oeuvre
tout à fait exceptionnelle et qui à mon
sens
n'a pas toujours été dans le suc à mon
sens n'a pas toujours été je dirais à
apprécier comme il fallait du côté des
politiques alors en deux mots
la sphère a commencé en 1981
ça s'appelle l'invention de la france
et
qui explique que bien sûr nous avons une
hétérogénéité foncière dans ce pays
mais que le besoin de faire france
finalement la longtemps emporté
et parce qu'on s'était ralliée
avec des
majorités variable avec des des
implantations régionales variable peu
importe le nom s'était rallié à l'idée
que pour faire france il faut promouvoir
l'homme avec un grand h
que c'est comme ça que les choses
évolueront et l'homme dans ses droits
non non c'est droits de l'homme et dès
le départ avec l'invention de la france
hervé lebras donne s'agirait sa
singularité le répète il va nous faire
constamment ce qu'il appelle un atlas
anthropologique et politique des choses
alors
dans une oeuvre qui continue qui est
très abondante internationalement aussi
un deuxième livre qui s'appelle les
trois france alors il s'en expliquera
peut-être tout à l'heure
l'idée est alors dans l'est dans l'es3
france à mon sens le doute s'installe un
peu est-ce que l'homme avec le grand son
grand h nous suffit pour expliquer enfin
le cours des choses et là il entreprend
de nous dire une espèce de géographie
secrète finalement où les relations
humaines et non pas simplement les
les rapports de classe enfin et c où les
rapports économiques où les relations
humaines
régis plus qu'on ne le croit et là
c'est ce que je dis dans le petit papier
avec les trois france il s'est imposé
et il est un des rares je le répète
sur l'idée assez simple
il faut à tout prix substituer à nos
visions parisienne à nos visions et
hiérarchisé à nos visions
socio-économique pour dire vite dans
l'air du temps n'étant 86 vous voyez il
faut constamment
inscrire installé me propager une vision
provincial une région une vision morcelé
une vision année anthropologique et
politiques et tu appelle ça un moment
l'histoire à l'envers dans dans l'es3
france et tu dois savoir que ça rend du
grand service est
là qu est ce qu on trouve derrière de la
religion des structures familiales des
du rapport au mariage à la vie à la mort
pour tous pour dire vite et toujours
avec ton ingéniosité carte graphique
alors un grand saut chronologique 2013
avec emmanuel todd un livre qui
s'appelle le mystère français
le doute installé après l'es3 france
perdure et alors là je termine d'une
phrase d'une de tes phrases
dans le mystère français
quitte un raisonnement comme toujours
anthropologique esterra et cartographié
je cite tous les changements actuels
respecte retrouve ou revivifie des
espaces anthropologique et religieux
anciens
il ya une espèce de socle là a
constamment étudier et lors du coup dans
le mystère français
tu expliques que notre pays souffre d'un
espèce de déséquilibre nouveau par non
reconnaissance de ceux de ce socle là et
que je cite le pays souffre d'un
déséquilibre nouveau entre les espaces
anthropologique et religieux qu'ils
constituent
son coeur libéral et égalitaire que fut
la révolution qui fit la révolution
française est affaibli
sa périphérie
autrefois périphérie par rapport à paris
et à l'état et tout ce qu'on veut sa
périphérie autrefois fidèle à l'idéal de
hiérarchie est souvent de tradition
catholique est désormais dominante nos
dirigeants
parce qu'ils ignorent tout du mode de
fonctionnement profonde leur propre pays
aggrave sa condition par des politiques
inadaptées
et leur dernière traduction c'est ça
cette année donc un atlas des inégalités
chez autrement ou du cartographie les
les territoires de l'inégalité
bref tu es en plein je dirais de façon
originale
depuis trente ans tu creuses tombant
entre ton sion et tu te trouves
aujourd'hui je dirais en pleine
actualité
vous avez entendu
le premier ministre sur france 2
dimanche chris paul la lutte contre les
inégalités toute la politique de goût du
gouvernement
vous avez entendu le premier secrétaire
du parti socialiste dans le jdd il
s'agit maintenant vraiment d'impulser la
lutte contre les inégalités
je te laisse la parole
merci
merci beaucoup jean pierre rioux pour 7h
introduction parfaitement historique
tu as sans doute raconter mon histoire
on entend oui et doit sans doute on fond
raconté beaucoup mieux mon histoire que
je n'aurais pu le faire ce que je vais
vous montrer ce soir c'est ça va tourner
autour du livre mais ont dû dernier
livre sur les inégalités mais je mens et
va dray un petit peu à la fin parce que
je pense que vous êtes beaucoup plus
concerné par le monde politique donc
sans j'essaierai de déboucher sur des
cartes politiques je vous montrerai vous
verrez les cartes par derrière
forcément en plus de ça elles seront
assez petit votre distance c'est ça sera
plus pour appuyer ce que je vous dirai
pas ce que souvent sur une carte donnée
c'est des cartes que
que je fais à l'échelle des communes
françaises donc c'est on a un rendu qui
est très fin et on peut s'attarder
longtemps mais ça sera plutôt poursuivre
une sorte de raisonnement qui m'amènera
à un constat politique
alors pourquoi justement les cartes et
il a fort bien dit c'est parce que c'est
le moyen c'est un une carte quand elle
est fine permet de saisir la vie
concrète dans des espaces
concrets permettent se poser des
questions à ce sujet là et de ne pas
raisonner avec des catégories socio
économique très générales qui sont
justement presque toujours utilisé parce
qu'elles sont vues de paris où elles
sont vues de
personnes qui circulent assez peu en
dehors de paris
alors la place des inégalités je l'avais
fait au fond pour pour
expliciter un
quelque chose qui était resté en plan
dans le livre précédent avec emmanuel
todd dans le mystère français d'un côté
on montrait élevé vous leur montrer
quelque chose qui est devenu assez
classique qui est la montée des
inégalités métropolitaine donc par
rapport au centre tout ce qui est la
distance par rapport aux centres des
grandes villes ou des grandes
agglomérations
et puis simultanément on montrait d'où
mon titre qu' il y avait indépendamment
des inégalités entre ville périphérie et
rural profond des inégalités fortes
entre alors j'ai employé le mot région
mais c'est pas qu'on pourra y revenir
dans les questions c'est pas les régions
au sens qui a été
invité ces derniers temps dans leur
fusion ces régions pour désigner d'assez
larges espaces plus tard justement que
des pays qui sont à plus petite échelle
et il y as tu voulais le voir de grosses
et vous le savez déjà sans doute mais ça
permettra de le préciser de très grosses
différences homme et des différences qui
s'accroissent entre régions françaises
parce que la question des inégalités
aussi si elle m'a intéressé dans cet
atlas c'est que la france a assez bien
résisté
globalement à la crise de 2008 en termes
d'inégalités quand on regarde les
données comparatives
vous savez que l'inégalité a explosé
dans les pays anglo-saxons et pas
seulement dans les pays anglo saxons au
brésil dans d'autres pays et en france
elle a été globalement un peu près
maîtriser mais certaines formes de ce
canton prendre certains domaines les
inégalités se sont accrues et c'est le
cas des inégalités dans l'espace
alors je serai de vous montrer assez
rapidement que là on peut la
métropolisation et des couches
protectrices donc à la fois ce qui se
passe au niveau des métropoles et ce qui
se passe dans cette coupure qui entre
régions au fond plus ou moins
en forme plus ou moins en crise elle
s'explique ou du moins elle elle se
ramène à aussi une coupure
sociale et à ce moment là elle permet à
un certain fond certaine compréhension
des différences politiques actuelles
dans les résultats des élections alors
la métropolisation
je vais là chaque fois que je le vrai ça
sera une
ope la carte suivante alors c'est une
carte qui remonte qui montre ici où
était quelle était la proportion de gens
de à ces deux jeunes de gens âgés de 20
à 24 ans en 1982
s'est dit donc la manière dont on
pressent fait presque toutes les cartes
ça s'appelle des cartes lycée c'est à
dire qu'au lieu de mettre chalon mais on
prend chaque commune mais on étale la
population de chaque commune autour et
de cette manière là vous voyez qu'on
retrouve mieux les villes et puis on
gomme les irrégularités c'est un peu
comme le lissage qu'on fait de courbes
économique de combes boursières ou de
courbe
de croissance
de mensuels qu'on va transformer pour en
tirer un trend de plus régulier voyez
que là il ya une zone où les jeunes sont
peu nombreux qui est en bleu presque
toujours là quand c'est fort ça sera un
rouge et brun quand c'est fait ça sera
en bleu et bleu foncé et là les jeunes
sont nombreux dans toute une france 2 du
nord et de l'est c'est lié à la fois une
plus forte fécondité de ces zones là qui
est encore vrai actuellement et aussi à
une migration de régions qui étaient
très peu industrialisé dans le dans le
sud donc là on a une quelque chose d'une
vision assez traditionnel puis bien sûr
il ya plus de jeunes dans dans les
villes mais regardez à la même échelle
maintenant dans dernier recensement
voilà là car c'est à dire pratiquement
dans tout l'espace rural les jeunes sont
devenus une classe d'âge très rare -4%
très souvent et inversement ils se sont
groupés dans
dans les villes alors il ya la montée de
l'éducation il et les jeunes là les
universités mais c'est beaucoup plus
large c'est au fond devenu une sorte de
deux moment du cycle de vie de
la jeunesse et je pense aura des
implications très importantes parce que
quand plus tard ces jeunes vont migrer
hors du centre ville mais ils auront eu
une toute une période de leur
socialisation qui se sera passée dans
dans cette ville j'ai pris 20 à 24 ans
et des régions pour des raisons de
données mais c'est ça déborde
24 ans peut étonner qui est un gros un
gros point rouge sur la corse la corse
n'est pas toujours très fiable les
données mais
il y a mais dans ce cas là sur ce cas là
c'est tout à fait fiable parce que en
fait c'est la petite ville de corte mais
la petite ville de corte à une est la
seule université
de corse et elle attire beaucoup de
beaucoup de jeunes donc cette fois ci
les corses ont été corrects en répondant
au recensement alors suivante cette
domination des grandes villes et des
métropoles par exemple voilà la
proportion de cadres actuellement vous
voyez que ils passent dans les zones
brand bleus elle passe de quatre pour
cent à plus de 24% dans les zones en en
brun foncé c'est une énorme différence
et vous voyez aussi autre chose sans
vouloir
titiller les réformes actuelles mais que
presque chaque préfecture apparaît
autrement dit il ya une réalité
dans l'espace de les préfectures les
départements ont fabriqué leur espace au
cours de plus de
de deux siècles pour des tas de raisons
mais vous le voyez vous voyez d'ailleurs
que c'est assez souvent sur les cartes
on voit que c'est les frontières entre
départements qui sont les plus
déshérités je montrerai pas
énormément de cartes mais sperme sur des
cartes du vieillissement sur des cartes
de la dépopulation voit que c'est les
frontières des départements qui donc il
ya une réalité elle est plus faible que
celle des métropoles que vous ayez bien
apparaître mais elle existe et c'est
assez normal parce que les au graff
savent bien qui a des fonctions de
l'hiérarchie zay pour les pour les
villes donc plus une ville à ses
fonctions plus elle attire les cadres et
c'est alors ce qui est peut-être plus
net c'est que cette concentration cette
carte la plus beau plus brouillés
montrent que la concentration des cadres
s'est accentuée dans l'est dans les
grandes métropoles voyait aussi que
c'est à leur voisinage bien sûr parce
qu'il ya le périurbain c'est un petit
peu plus large mais c'est à nouveau un
phénomène qui est en marche c'est pas
simplement un phénomène que qu'on
constate même chose pour l'ailé alors
une lindsay une catégorie qui s'appelle
cadres intermédiaires ou une profession
intermédiaire c'est un peu les cadres
moyens ces techniciens c'est infirme
infirmiers infirmières personnel de
maîtrise et prik c'est un peu la même
chose avec au delà des métropoles on
voit justement des villes moyennes des
préfectures qui
qui apparaissent
une à une et pas de verre bourges qui
sont quand même pas des métropoles mais
qui sont des villes de caen une
importance au moins départemental par
leur statut
et là la présence la concentration des
professions intermédiaires dans les
zones métropolitaines est elle-même
hiérarchiser volage ici j'ai mis la
proportion de cadres les professions
libérales par rapport à l'ensemble
quatre supérieurs et cadres moyens donc
par rapport à l'ensemble des cadres et
des professions intermédiaires et vous
voyez plus et foncez plus les cadres
représentent une fraction importante
donc qu'il ya comme des anneaux
successifs bien sûr ces statistiques des
professions intermédiaires au centre des
deals des cadres qui sont en périphérie
mais la tendance générale est à une
sorte de tri qui s'opèrent par couronne
successives autour des des grandes
métropoles vous me direz les ouvriers
ben je vais vous montrer
voilà les ouvriers en en 1982 et très
vite je vais demander à ce qu'on fasse
aussi y ait la paix met la carte
suivante qui sont les ouvriers
maintenant comme proportion de la
population active voyez comment il ya
d'abord eu un repli et c'est les cartes
ne sont pas à la même échelle la
proportion d'ouvriers a beaucoup diminué
mais quand on fait bouger 7
on passe d'une carte à l'autre on voit
comment ça c'est creuser autour des
métropoles et des grandes villes les
ouvriers sont devenus assez souvent des
ruraux la proportion de d'ouvriers vous
le voyez même la plus forte sur la
frontière de département ne surent et à
une zone par exemple dans
bien connue de détail heures pour
l'industrie qui est le choletais qui est
à la frontière de la vendée de du maine
et loire et de la 2 cv de la loire
atlantique mais on voit aussi dans les
vosges où on voit aussi à la frontière
de l'aisne et du nord est ou bien à
l'affront qui ont bien la frontière de
la somme et du pas de calais on a donc
il ya une sorte de repli de l'industrie
et surtout de repli des ouvriers parce
qu'ils se déplacent pour aller dans les
entreprises qui fait qu'ils sont en
train de devenir plus ruraux que les
agriculteurs eux mêmes puisque les
agriculteurs ont vu leur statut beaucoup
peut évoluer beaucoup d'entre eux
maintenant proportion qui est de l'ordre
du tiers habitent en ville pour les
études des enfants pour des tas de
raisons donc quelque part on a une
france bizarre où les matins laine et
ouvriers se dirigent de la campagne vers
la ville et croiser agriculteurs qui se
dirigent de la ville vers la campagne
et c'est encore plus étonnant quand on
prend la carte suivante qui sont la
profession d'artisan et petits
commerçants donc vous voyez que les
ouvriers sont au nord les artisans et
petits commerçants sont au sud bien sûr
à nouveau c'est une proportion c'est des
statistiques mais c'est quand même assez
bizarre comme comme pays c'est quand
vous avez besoin d'un artisan au nord ou
d'un ouvrier au sud ça paraît un peu
plus compliqué vu cette séparation alors
on va retrouver
7,7
aspect du sud dernier point sur la
métropolisation c'est le plus le plus
connu mais n'a cartes et là c'est une
carte qui n'est pas laisser l ai fait
commune par commune et c'est la carte du
revenu médian par individu ils
vouvoyaient que là on voit à nouveau
apparaître les
villes très importante mais aussi
justement les villes moyennes où les
préfectures et voyez que on devine
presque les frontières des départements
aux zones qui sont le plus bleu foncé
c'est à dire où ses revenus individuels
sont les plus faibles c'est une carte
pied
mériterait beaucoup plus de commentaires
il ya des particularités sur les
frontières en champagne et cetera mais
globalement elle montre bien cette
puissance que compte acquise les les
métropoles et cette concentration des
revenus les plus élevés et à cartes
suivantes montrent qu'elle a augmenté au
cours des halles or c'est plus difficile
les questions de données sur les revenus
mais dont je n'ai que sur les douze
dernières années mais on voit que la
concentration s'est opéré à un niveau un
peu plus large m'avait en débordant d
une métropole elle même de l'espace des
centres de vider de leur première
périphérie mais c'est quand même dans
les régions les plus metropolis et que
la croissance des revenus a été la plus
la plus forte donc on a tout un paquet
qui montre cette métropolisation mais ce
paquet la ferait oublier que des
différences subsistent importante et
qu'on voit mal qui sont pense beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus difficilement
perceptible que ce phénomène de
métropolisation qui est mondiale qu'elle
est là voilà par exemple une carte qui
montre la halde et on entre dans les
inégalités qui montre les inégalités
locale donc on rapporte la frontière des
des vins bien quelles frontières de
revenus se trouvent les 20% les plus
riches
à quelles frontières de revenus se
trouvent les 20% les plus pauvres et on
obtient cette carte alors les villes
apparaissent bien sûr comme un peu plus
inégal ne serait ce que par exemple vous
avez qui avait les cadres elle est
revenu élevé mais il ya aussi vous
l'avez vu les jeunes et les jeunes sont
maintenant la fraction la plus pauvre de
la population c'est donc c'est assez non
son poste dire que c'est normal était
exagéré mais c'est assez naturel de
retrouver ces différences dans les
villes par contre voyez quel deux types
qu'on n'a pas la carte là
on a et vous voyez à quel point là on a
deux types de on a deux types de région
pour donner l'ordre de grandeur dans les
zones en bleu par exemple le grand ouest
mais aussi le le sud ouest est le plus
au sud mais aussi vous le voyez une
partie de l'alsace une partie des
de la savoie et des des alpes la
différence est pas très élevée elle est
de 1 à 2 mais si vous êtes dans la zone
nord de la france où si vous êtes au
tour la méditerranée la différence monte
à 1 à 3 et demi presque un à quatre
c'est presque le double c'est donc pas
la même chose comme inégalités dans les
zones de l'ouest et dans les zones est
et dans les zones du
du pourtour méditerranéen et de la
frontière nord-est
c'est donc pas simplement un phénomène
urbain on voit apparaître ce phénomène
de ville cartes suivantes
presque naturellement cette carte là
alors elle est inversée parce que c'est
le revenu des plus pauvres c'est à
partir de quel revenu on tombe dans les
10% les plus pauvres est payé que le
bleu foncé cc 10% les plus pauvres
si on est dans le languedoc-roussillon
où bien sûr la barre nord-est c'est 4000
euros par an ça fait
quand 300 euros par mois un peu plus de
300 euros par mois si on est dans les
zones de l'arc atlantique comme on dit
parfois ou bien le rhône alpes ou bien
de l'alsace ses 12000 euros ces douze
mille roses veut dire 1000 euros par
mois c'est pas le même type de de
pauvreté et 12000 euros par mois c'est
pas c'est bien sûr peu mais c'est quand
même quelque chose qui permet de vivre
tandis que 4000 euros par mois là on
commence à arriver à un niveau de 4000
euros par an oui oui
oui c'est des revenus bruts ainsi des
revenus déclarés au
ces chiffres sont obtenus à partir des
revenus déclarés à l'administration des
finances sont sans tenir compte des de
tout ce que sont les allocations
tout ce qui est social et c'est ramener
au niveau des individus parce qu'on a
les revenus seulement par ménage avec un
procédé pondération qu'on appelle les
celle d'oxford m'enfin je pense certains
d'entre vous sont familiarisés avec ça
mais ça permette de cette manière là
d'avoir des revenus indépendamment de la
taille des ménages avoir des revenus qui
sont des revenus individuels
suivante même chose pour ouvriers les
verrez apparaître ce type de carte pour
les familles monoparentales où là aussi
de très gros écarts existent puisque
dans les zones les plus
bleu foncé ces familles monoparentales
c'est moins du douzième des des familles
alors que dans les zones en brun rouge
et brun on atteint un cinquième ont
atteint 20 % des familles voyez que ce
n'est pas simplement un fait urbain les
familles monoparentales sont plus
urbaine que les autres on voit les
points urbain parce mais là on a la
carte wi dakar mais on voit aussi toute
une zone pareil un nouveau la zone
languedocienne pin partie de la zone
nord-est suivante même chose pour pour
le taux de chômage où on voit la nouveau
de grosses différences de taux de
chômage on a l'habitude de raisonner
avec le taux de chômage national
quelquefois parfois aller tout régionaux
mais vous voyez que ces différences sont
très importantes
sur l'ensemble de la france et chose
peut-être plus inquiétante voilà la même
carte en 1982 alors c'est pas la même
échelle le chômage était plus fait bien
sûr que maintenant mais à peu de choses
près vous avez
vous avez la même structure qui apparaît
ya eu des progrès notamment sur l'arc
atlantique et puis
démonté plus forte du chômage notamment
sur la partie centrale de la france mais
la caractéristique nord-est et
méditerranéennes subsistent même chose
pour vais vous lasser mais je crois que
c'est la dernière pour les pourcentages
de personnes de 25 à 34 ans qui n'ont
pas de diplôme alors là on entre sur un
autre gros problème français voyez
réapparaître alors c'est jamais
exactement la même carte mais à chaque
fois c'est des différences très faible
de très forte puisque c'est plus du
simple au double dans les zones en bleu
c'est
6,6 et demi pour cent de son diplôme
dans les zones en brun foncé c'est
plutôt qu'une ces 15% de 200 diplôme l'a
à nouveau on a de très grosses
différences et qui sont pas des
différences
liées à la métropolisation qui sont des
différences liées à des caractères
régionaux qui dit alors quelles sont ces
caractères régionaux la proposition
qu'on avait fait avec emmanuel todd
était de dire ces cartes là et vous
allez le voir recoupent deux phénomènes
très ancien et jean pierre rioux il a
fait allusion
c'est un la présence de la religion dans
sommes plus forte dans certaines
beaucoup plus forte dans certaines
parties de la france que dans d'autres
et la présence de structures familiales
ancien différentes c'est des choses très
anciennes qui sont de moins en moins
perceptibles pour les structures
familiales presque toutes les structures
observer maintenant son nucléaire mais
les modes de vie induits par ces
structures les comportements sont restés
notamment des comportements de
coopération entre générations ou des
comportements de voisinage les
comportements de solidarité qui sont
tout à fait différent on s'explique sur
la raison de ces comportements qui sont
justement pour ça que le mot
anthropologique a été utilisé ces des
comportements de proximité et ce qui se
passer le mot coucher un peu une
allusion à cela c'est qu'au fond la
couche duo qui est la couche de la
situation actuelle citation t'a donné
correspond assez bien cela la couche duo
qui était la couche étatique s'est
affaibli et donc les couches
protectrices comme on les appelait
jouent un beau coup plus grand rôle elle
joue un rôle au fond de deux filets de
de protection et là où elle n'existe pas
ce fil n existe pas et donc les haies
les régions qui sont dans ce cas là ont
plus de difficultés puisque elle
reposait beaucoup plus sur l'aide de
l'état est beaucoup moins sûre des
solidarités locales ces solidarités
locales ce sont donc deux types
ça c'est là une carte qu'on peut tracer
encore maintenant c'est là
c'est la carte des structures familiales
c'est disons dans dans les zones qui
sont en rouge et embrun et y compris
surtout en la partie alsacienne aussi
c'est ce qu'on appelle hamissou c'est à
dire des familles qui sont orientés vers
la transmission ont été famille qui
historiquement était dans des régions
d'héritage inégalitaire et par un
paradoxe mais j'ai pas le temps de le
développer l'héritage inégalitaire a en
fait engendré de légalité parce qu'on
transmet les shops artisanales ou bien
on transmet la la propriété foncière
l'exploitation agricole dans son entier
alors que dans les régions du nord
particulièrement les régions du nord-est
de chant ouvert on a procédé à cause de
l'héritage inné et à causeur étage
égalitaire à des divisions successives
et ses intérêts c'est général c'est que
quand on à l'égalité pour un certain
phénomène il on peut avoir un autre
phénomène perturbateurs qui entraîne une
grande inégalité beaucoup plus forte on
aurait pu l'imaginer
alors que s'il y avait eu un correctif
de l'inégalité le phénomène qui entraîne
qui a entraîné la
l'éclatement et la pulvérisation des
possessions agricole dans le nord-est
c'est la différence de fécondité quand
vous avez deux familles deux générations
de suite six enfants
chacun à 1 36e quand vous avez deux
générations suite à un enfant unique
vous avez chacun où l'enfant riddick
tout seul à 1 donc en rien quand deux
générations vous passée de
1,36 et c'est les régions du nord-est
c'est leur histoire ce que c'est pas
deux générations c'est
historiquement on peut tracer l'héritage
égalitaire et la famille nucléaire bien
avant l'industrialisation à partir de 10
ans à partir de la renaissance on en est
pratiquement sûr et d'ailleurs ils
s'inverse le raisonnement c'est parce
que il y avait eu cet héritage
égalitaire qui a eu constitution d'un
prolétariat agricole 80% au recensement
de 1851 80% des paysans étaient les
ouvriers agricoles des journaliers on
disait à l'époque il avait il restait
quelques lopins de terre mais ne
pouvaient pas survivre seul pas donc ils
louaient leurs bras on les appelait
aussi gracié ouary côtier s'il avait un
cheval alors que si vous étiez dans
l'aveyron dans la lozère ou dans le lot
c'était 75% de paysans petit
propriétaire c'est donc l'héritage
inégalitaire avait fabriqué l'égalité
paradoxalement et l'héritage égalitaire
à fabriquer l'inégalité et cette
inégalité dans le nord a formé ce
prolétariat agricole qui plus tard a
servi bien entendu de prolétariat
ouvriers à l'industrie donc la cause est
plutôt dans le sens
la structure familiale a conditionné une
structure industrielle qu en sens
inverse qui était classique dans les
faits les auteurs de la fin du 19e
siècle qui accuse l industrie d'avoir
brisé la famille et c'est un grand
historien anglais peter l'athlète qui au
fond montrer le renversement de la
causalité parce qu en angleterre aussi
ces mêmes phénomènes se sont reproduits
donc là vous avez une carte de de fond
ce qu'était ce cas était un type de
famille qui a influencé très fortement
un grand nombre de rapports sociaux
élémentaires et un anthropologue
français georges auguste as a résumé
d'une formule la différence entre au
fond le nord de la loire et le sud de la
loire en disant au nord de la loire en
hérite d'un nom au sud de la loire on
hérite d'une maison et au nord de la
loire un nom ça se divise alors qu'au
sud de la loire une maison en général ça
ne se divise pas donc ces deux le type
de société qui ont profondément marqué
la qui ont profondément coupé là la
france est le second une seconde couche
protectrice mais je suis devant un
auditoire qui la connaître sans doute
même mieux que moi c'est la couche
religieuse et là vous avez une carte qui
donne
c'est une très belle enquête dans les
années 60 sur la pratique religieuse qui
a été effectué par chaque curé de
paroisse rurale et qui a noté sur une
année combien de personnes venaient
régulièrement à la messe de dimanche
c'est ce qu'on appelle les messalisants
et on a rapporté ce nombre de personnes
à la population de plus de 20 ans
recensement pour vous donner les
chiffres dans les zones en bleu foncé
c'est plus de 90% d'assistance à la
messe dans les années 60 dans les zones
embrun c'est parfois proche de zéro pour
cent ces deux france là dedans et la ja
toute l'histoire politique est derrière
et c'est très anciens voilà une carte
qu'on a pu tracer grâce un très beau
travail d'un historien américain timothy
tackett qui montre à la révolution
comment ces 16 la france s'est coupé en
deux parce que les curés et prêtre
devait prêter serment à la constitution
et dans certaines régions ils ont prêté
massivement serment vous voyez c'est
désolant brun et on les a appelés les
curés jure heures et dans d'autres
régions c'est celle qui sont en bleu ils
ont refusé c'était les réfractaires et
cette coupure est resté pratiquement la
même
on peut dire jusqu'à jusqu'à maintenant
il se trouve que j'ai pu
grâce à une petit artifice avec jérôme
fourquet
avoir une idée de ce qu'était
aujourd'hui la pratique religieuse en
france elle a beaucoup baissé par
rapport à globalement elle était de plus
de 40% dans les années 60 et les 13%
maintenant mais c'est pratiquement la
même carte avec peut-être un petit
monter des justement des villes mais à
part cela on retrouve cette cette très
grosse coupure et du coup quand vous
mettez suivante quand vous êtes une
sorte de combinaison de ces deux couches
protectrices plus et foncez plus alors
vous voyez d'un côté là la plus belle
des créations selker en eau le plus à
gauche c'est là la carte des structures
familiales celle qui est en bas le plus
à droite c'est la carte religieuse la
carte de la pratique catholique et j'ai
simplement mêlés les deux dans les
cartes intermédiaires et voyez que quand
on les mène à peu près à égalité de
variations dans la quartier alors en eau
sur la droite on obtient une forme qui
reprend assez bien là les différences
qu'on a vue qui laisse assez bien qui
sépare assez bien les régions où vous
avez vu les inégalités étaient plus fait
des régions où ces inégalités étaient
plus fortes la seule zone où les
désaccords forts c'est le grand bassin
parisien et la présence de paris change
justement les au fond les questions de
couche protectrice
il ya une influence fortes de
de paris y compris d'ailleurs dans les
déplacements
alors
je vais maintenant assez rapidement vous
montrer que les deux la métropolisation
et des couches protectrices peuvent se
combiner ainsi on prend un point de vue
social occupe tout à fait simple
d'ailleurs qui va être là en coupant la
crosse aux maux de la société en deux et
je vais vous montrer il va y avoir une
succession de cartes qui va montrer une
évolution
je vais regarder selon les catégories
sociales où se trouvent les plus
diplômés de la catégorie sociale données
demandées on prend on va prendre là par
exemple c'est les cadres on regarde
quels sont les cadres qui ont un diplôme
n'est que plus de 2 ans de 1 diplôme non
plus de deux ans après le bac et là on a
cette proportion en
1982 on voit apparaître les villes mais
pas tout on voit des zones c'est encore
une france industrielle des cats sont
des ingénieurs météo en lorraine dont
qui sont les habitent à proximité ou sur
le bassin houiller ou sur la métallurgie
et la même carte maintenant suivante ah
voilà trois ans dit les cadres les plus
diplômés se sont concentrées dans les
métropoles c'est pas simplement comme la
première carte vous avez vu que les
cadres et était bien sûr plus fréquents
dans la métropole mais c'est les cas des
plus diplômés une fois qu'on l'a dit bon
on se dit ben bien sûr céline et c'est
naturel mais j'ai été frappé par la
rapidité de cette évolution est sans
doute aussi parce que ce ne sont plus
des cadres industriels sont maintenant
une minorité donc c'était cadres qui
sont plus dans les services où dans même
dans la finance et qui sont à ce moment
là dans les centres-villes donc qian
particularité qui s'est renforcée de ces
dans ces grandes métropoles si on
regarde suivante les les professions
intermédiaires voyez que là
c'était
c'était une carte qui était restée
largement régionales avec curieusement
alors j'ai pris ce qu'ils avaient au
moins le bac en 1982 et dans ces
professions intermédiaires il y avait
une domination du sud et de l'ouest si
vous les prenez maintenant vous avez
cela vous voyez que les
les villes sont apparus très nettement
alors il reste un aspect régional et
vous regarde marc rich cet aspect
régional est très proche la ou les
professions intermédiaires sont plus
diplômées en dehors des villes
c'est presque pas loin de la carte
religieuse de la carte des zones qui
étaient les plus catholiques que vous
avez vus auparavant et là il ya une une
explication bien nouveau c'est le fait
de la couche protectrice et si
maintenant vous passez de l'autre côté
vous prenez les ouvriers les employés
alors voilà où étaient les prix la
proportion d'employés qui avaient
au moins le ca paie donc il pouvait
avoir nettement plus mais au moins le ca
fait en 1982 voyez que c'est une carte
où on voit apparaître les villes mais
aussi des zones à nouveau d'ailleurs
assez largement les zones de couche
protectrice et regardez ce qui s'est
passé maintenant car tu es devenu près
des villes sont pratiquement
imperceptible à part quelques unes qui
mais qui sont pas de grosses villes
d'ailleurs après tout blois paraît
genoux non orléans je ne sais pas
vraiment pourquoi mais les grosses
villes mettons lyon mettons lille
mettons même nantes n'apparaissent plus
ce différence plus en revanche vous
voyez qu'on a bien dans les régions de
couche protectrice ou là
les employés sont le plus diplômé et si
vous prenez les ouvriers c'est
exactement une chose voilà où étaient
les ouvriers les plus diplômés alors
c'est au moins le ca paix comme pour les
employés vous voyez que c'était il y
avait à certaines zones mais aussi on
voyait on voit bien apparaître la
plupart des villes est actuellement donc
près de trente ans plus tard voilà où
sont les ouvriers qui sont les plus
diplômés cette fois ci on ne voit
absolument plus la présence de métropole
et on voit au contraire
ces zones donc les zones catholique et
les zones anciennement de famille sous
joug de famille
complexe alors pourquoi cette coupure
s'est opéré je pense que pour les cadres
moyens et cadres supérieurs
l'espace est devenu relativement
homogène il est marqué par les ce qui
est important dans l'espace donc la
concentration de certaines activités
compris des activités de haut niveau en
revanche je pense que pour les ouvriers
pour les employés dans les couches
protectrices le fait des ouvriers ou des
employés
on a en est on allé steam de son
voisinage si on peut dire on est reconnu
dans la salle on est dans une société
qui a des solidarités et où on trouve sa
place alors que dans les zones les plus
métropolitaine et dans les zones où vous
avez vu il n'y a pas chez couche
protectrice
les personnes sont beaucoup plus ou
abandonnés ou marginalisées quand elles
sont quand elles font partie des des
classes populaires je vais tirer un
argument là j'ai terminé la partie
sociale et rapidement se montrer
quelques cartes politiques parce que je
vais en tirer un argument sur des
questions politiques alors ça sera plus
les américains direct et yvain ça c'est
plus un essai que mes seins repose aussi
sur des données tout aussi sérieusement
baissé de vous montrer quelques cartes
qui il lit la politique à ces couches
protectrices voilà là je reprends la
carte et que vous avez déjà vu que je
programme ans est un autre critère mais
presque le même qui vous montrent la
présence encore maintenant dès la
dernière trace de ces structures
familiales
parce que j'ai pas la possibilité de
quatre tracés des cartes fine avant les
années récentes les maintenant on peut
disposer de données de fichiers
importants à l'insee mais pour les
recensements plus anciens bien sûr on a
seulement les départements
et là je vous ai mis quatre cartes qui
m'ont toujours
considéré qu'ils sont alors en a deux
qui sont tout à fait
simple qui sont les deux du bas c'est
ségolène royal et hollande au second
tour de
de 2012 j'ai donc vous voyez que assez
curieusement on pourrait dire la famille
souche m ou les couches protectrices n
les socialistes parce que
vous remarquerez que ça n'a rien à voir
avec les zones jeunes ni rien à voir
avec les zones où sont les ouvriers donc
là vous avez
vous avez ça et manière une énigme vous
remarqué aussi que bien sûr les deux
cartes sont pas à la même échelle il ya
la différence de pourcentage qui a fait
que l'un a gagné et l'autre a perdu mais
quand on les ramène justement on en
tient contente donc on décale l'échelle
de cinq points voyez que les cartes sont
de façon extraordinaire les mêmes c'est
quand même là un point qui m'a et du
coup j'ai regardé j'ai regardé au
premier tour mais n'ont pas ce qu'avait
obtenu ségolène royal et
hollande mais j'ai regardé ce qu'il
avait obtenu ce qu'ils avaient obtenues
par rapport à hollande autrement dit
j'ai fait comme si les autres candidats
sous suis désolé mais n'avait pas été
présent et donc j'ai regardé le duel
entre les deux et regardez ce qui se
passe
quand les deux cartes duos et la part
que représentent au premier tour
ségolène royal sur ségolène royal plus
sarkozy et même chose pour land les
cartes sont exactement mais les mêmes
qu'au second tour c'est comme si le
premier tour donnait le second tour rien
que par l'opposition de du candidat
socialiste et du candidat
ump de sarkozy d'ailleurs puisqu'il est
né le même j'ai pas d'explication mais
il ya quelque chose de
ce qui m'intrigue et qui me dit aussi
que les comportements politiques sont
peut-être plus tape qu'on imagine
quelquefois c'est il ya
totalement stable là dans un cas comme
ça
c'est assez sidérant c'est les
coefficients de corrélation tous ces
trucs statistiques donnent des des
valeurs qu'on rencontre extrêmement
rarement alors bon je vous ai pas mis
une carte de la démocratie chrétienne
vous savez que c'est très proche de la
carte religieuse mais vais vous montrer
j'ai la carte religieuse actuelle voyez
voilà la carterie gras alors c'est une
carte qui a été tracé voyez qu'on
retrouve le lait les grands alors c'est
une carte qu'on a pu tracer avec jérôme
fourquet de l'ifop il a mis ensemble 50
enquêtes de l'ifop 2000 personnes en
2012 dans laquelle la question de la
religion était posée et du coup est allé
poser on avait la commune de la personne
qui répondait donc au lieu d'avoir mille
réponses qui ne permettait pas du tout
de voir régionalement on a eu un peu
plus de cinquante mille
réponses et on a pu comme c'était la
même question n'a pu tracer la carte que
vous voyez qui reprend lauriad et
justement comme vous laisse y aller on
voit que paris la pratique religieuse a
un peu augmenté en fait alors que bien
entendu elle a plutôt baissé partout
beaucoup baissé partout ailleurs mais
elle a baissé régulièrement c'est-à-dire
les zones les plus catholiques sont
restés les zones les plus catholiques et
les zones les plus
laïcs et un mauvais termes les plus
déchristianisée sont restés les zones
n'est plus déchristianisée ya comme dans
d comme c'est fait avec seulement 50
mille enfin c'est déjà beaucoup mais il
ya des petites irrégularités vous voyez
le haut du cotentin je sais pas je peux
pas donner de l'efficace ion mais c'est
ce qui est frappant supprimer cette
carte là je vais vous donner une carte
politique c'est la carte des oui et des
non au référendum de 2005 et voyait que
les c'est pratiquement bon il ya des
nuances mais c'est pratiquement la même
carte est d'ailleurs sur presque tous
les référendum on a cela c'est à dire
c'est la france qui a
voté oui au référendum c'est la france
catholique assez largement quand on
prend le dessin est scellé quelques
grandes métropoles en plus moi là là
mais vous avez vu que c'était sur la
carte religieuse actuelle la même
combinaison alors l'explication là aussi
je crois remonte aux couches
protectrices et raison catholique en
france ne sont pas des régions qui sont
quand une raison immémoriale d'être
catholique là c'est presque toujours sur
moment la révolution sans doute que la
coupure s'est créé le plus fortement ses
des régions qui en général avait d
autonomie ou des libertés locales y
avait des parlements en bretagne avait
des
l'alsace et la lorraine était encore
dans le saint-empire donc c'est des
régions qui ont mal supporté la
l'unification
fond le jacobinisme le fait que
désormais toutes les règles soient les
mêmes pour pour toute la france non
c'est une façon d'expliquer le la
coupure entre les curés jure heures et
puis les les curés
réfractaires et du coup chaque fois
qu'il ya eu un référendum qui portait au
fond sur une diminution des béni des
pouvoirs de l'état central que ce soit
régionalisation ou europe on a cette
même carte qui est apparu sur chaque
référendum on a sept cette carte c'est
la france catholique qui a dit oui à la
régionalisation oui à l'europe et la
france
déchristianisée qui a dit et non alors
j'ai terminé par deux petites choses une
chose qui tout ça c'est aussi c'est plus
hypothétique mais j'ai fait autre chose
explique devant votre auditoire pense
que ça
peut vous intéresser parce que j'ai
regardé au niveau des cantons qui était
le niveau le plus fin que j'avais quelle
est la différence entre les voix de
hollande au second tour de
2012 et les voix de mitterrand au second
tour de 1980 comment trente années
s'était passé ça vous donne cette carte
qui est pas hélas il n'y a pas de
lissage la carte est faite canton par
canton et voyez qu'elle est
extraordinairement homogène et vous ne
pouvez pas manquer de voir que
battraient largement ses des zones qui
étaient au fond les honneurs et les
zones
religieuse ou de pratiques catholiques
mais aussi les zones un cellier à foin
siegfried et puis ensuite rené rémond
parlait de tempérament c'est une zone
qui ont un terrain tempérament qui a été
illustré par a notamment le mrp revoyait
que l'alsace est nettement l'est est
nettement moins fort et au fond lesté
nettement moins fort parce qu'il s'est
passé autre chose donc il ya eu tu te
sens des manières une conversion du
centre au moins pour le second tour pour
vers le candidat
socialiste et
c'est pas partout parce qu'il ya eu les
pertes qui sont en bleu et un rouge
c'est les gains on vous voyait est en
perte les pertes qui sont en bleu
suivante
bon c'est pour moi c'est ben c'est la
carte des votes à nouveau au niveau
des
cantons pour le front national donc
c'est ce qu'a perdu la gauche et quand
vous combinez les deux vous vous comme
je l'avais fait pour la famille et pour
la religion vous voulez mais tu es l'une
sur l'autre et puis vous pondéré et vous
trouvez là deux cartes sont
la carte qui est sur la gauche c'est la
carte réelle de la différence entre
mitterrand entre hollande et mitterrand
et la gare de droite c'est la
combinaison carte religieuse plus ou
moins aux nationales et voyez que
on a très très alors demandé mais j'ai
oublié de le dire quand il ya des blancs
c'est il se trouve qu'en
1965 certains dans certains départements
l'évêché a pas pas répercuter la
consigne donc on saura pas ce qui se
passait dans la haute-vienne non sans
doute un il devait pas y avoir beaucoup
de pratique religieuse
mais ce qui manque malheureusement c'est
le seul à l'est ça sort là ça nous
manque beaucoup la moselle est bon et
donc voyez comment quelque part il ya un
sur deux résumés des trente années qui
m'apparaît assez intéressant sur le
l'évolution des votes je vais terminer
par là je vais appeler politiques et des
espoirs j'aurai à les dire j'aurais pu
mettre déception mais cette proche du
désespoir je vais reprendre les cinq
cartes où on voyait qu'il y avait des
régions qui se portait mal et d'autres
qui se portait mieux c'est vous les
rappels juste là
et si vous mettez ces cinq cartes
ensemble
vous donc là il ya une tonne t petite
technique statistique qui permet comme
elles se ressemblent assez on etc
servent à extraire la carte la plus
ressemblante aux cinq souris qui
extraient le plus de la variation des
cinq et on obtient sa alors allé il ya
des fluctuations mais on commençait à
deviner ce qui va apparaître une fois
que j'aurai fait un lissage une fois que
j'ai fait un lissage voilà ce qui
apparaît et là c'est problématique parce
que si vous maintenant si vous le
rapprocher la carte du front national
et voilà pour terminer les deux
front national
les deux les deux cartes sont en
principe totalement indépendante avait
pris sur celle de droite les cinq
régions qui vont mal les cinq critères
socio-économiques donc chômage sans
diplômes et des différents inégalités de
revenus faibles revenus des plus pauvres
familles monoparentales et puis sur la
carte de de gauche vous avez le score de
marine le pen en 2012 alors il ya une
différence qui est importante très
importante parce que elle pèse lourd
c'est les grandes villes vous voyez que
là les grandes villes sur la carte du
front national seront bleus c'est un md
des creux et vous le souhaitez très
largement commenté jusqu'à l'allée
maximum de front national à 30 km du
centre des villes etc ya eu beaucoup de
travaux sur ce sujet mais si maintenant
au foncier boucle mon exposé et que je
m'excuse d'avoir été un peu long mais il
ya une sorte de démonstration on peut
dire que on explique avec ce que vous
avez entendu là ma carte du front
national d'un côté j'explique mal ou du
moins je montre comment des courants
très profond
conditionne la carte de la gauche où il
est donc aussi de la droite et aussi du
centre mais c'est des cartes au fond qui
traduisent à mon avis des aspirations et
de l'autre côté on a la carte qui
traduit des déceptions voire peut-être
le désespoir les espoirs je pense qu on
vote plus mais au moins des déceptions
et danses et des déceptions on retrouve
les deux phénomènes sur lequel j'ai
insisté au milieu d'exposer on voit que
qu'est-ce qu'ils votent pour le front
national d'une part c'est dans les zones
où il n'ya pas de couche protectrice et
etc dans les zones on est loin des
métropoles et vous avez vu que c'était
les moins éduquées des cadres et des
professions intermédiaires qui est elle
plus loin des métropoles et que c'était
les moins éduquées des
des premiers ou catégories populaires
employés ouvriers qui étaient dans les
zones qui ce qui se portait mal donc on
là une sorte de de bouclage on ne pourra
pas savoir si effectivement la clientèle
fn autour des villes et plus constitué
au fonds de 4 qui ne sont pas arrivés à
aller vers le centre ville et puis plus
constitué de d'ouvriers d'employés qui
se sentent marginalisés ou qui sont
marginalisés dans les deux zones
des grands dans un grand nord-est et
puis la zone méditerranéenne qui sont
les zones sans couche protectrice
m'enfin là là dans le bouclage est assez
est assez impressionnant je vous
remercie de votre attention
bien merci beaucoup
mais j'avais trouvé que les 400 premiers
points et rôles est relativement
optimiste finalement et leur brusquement
à la fin
le désespoir arrive ce si j'ai bien
compris
le vote front national
c'est un vote qui subit une double peine
si je commence à la fois éloignement des
maisons et métropole et absence de deux
couches protect de couche protectrice
les questions ne vont pas manquer
oui non ces catholiques c'est on a dans
le travail qu'on a fait avec pour choeur
on a la preuve on a pas la pratique mais
on a les réponses
ce qu'ils se sont dit protestants en
en 2002 douce et un peu moins de 2% de
oui de la population et c'est resté très
typé donc c'est pas dans les cartes de
président en exercice et l'alsace c'est
l'alsace mais c'est aussi celle et
cévennes c'est le revers sud est du
massif central et simplement la partie
j'avais une carte plus anciennes qui le
seul recensement français qui a demandé
la religion et en 1872 et la carte est
pratiquement la même pour les cévennes
et pour l'alsace mais il y avait une
zone protestante encore importante en
1872 qui était disons dans sud des deux
sèvres baldizon de la rochelle à la
garonne qui a pratiquement là
qui est encore à plus à l'état de
reliques de
que aussi forte qu'elle était donc à une
petite variation j'étais faire une
remarque qui va vous surprendre mais il
y avait aussi dans
ceux qui ont répondu que musulman comme
religion donc ça permet sur c'est quand
même un peu plus de 50000 personnes on a
alors aucun sur aucune surprise c'est
bien sûr la carte de l'immigration
maghrébine là vraiment c'est juste une
vérification mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est que ceux qui ont répondu musulmans
donc on sait pas si pratique ou non ils
ont dit musulman de la même manière qu
par contre pour les catholiques la carte
que vous avez vu c'est ceux qui
pratiquent et on a aussi la carte qui à
peu près la même d'ailleurs de ceux qui
se disent catholiques mais non
pratiquant et pour les musulmans
globalement pratiquants et non
pratiquants ces 2 8 % des réponses 2 8 %
des réponses ça représente pour 65
millions d'habitants ça représente à peu
près un million huit cent mille
musulmans donc je pense que les chiffres
qui circulent 5 ou 6 millions sont des
chiffres absolument exagérés dont je ne
vois d'ailleurs personne n'est capable
d'en dire l'origine là au moins on a un
début de réponse alors on peut dire oui
peut-être certains musulmans qu'il était
non pas voulu dire qu'ils l'étaient
oui peut-être c'est possible mais enfin
passer de 1,1 million 800 mille à
cinq ou six millions d'âmes et derrière
ça voudrait dire que les trois quarts
des musulmans voudraient pas dire qu'ils
sont musulmans là je commence à douter
à c'est une belle idée
et oui non c'est une blague
il ya un passage très célèbre de
du livre d'andré sic street qui le
tableau politique de la france de
l'ouest qui commence il commence il
entre dans la france de l'ouest par les
le sud de la vendée des deux sèvres et
tout d'un coup alors là on est en pays
laïc et tout d'un coup peu au dessus de
fontenay le comte ça devient pays de
droite et catholique et il dit il a
cette phrase qui restent et ses lèvres
il dit le calcaire produits
l'instituteur et le granit produit le
curé
on a juste
tout cas chez nous dans le sud ouest il
ya une chose qui marche alors vraiment
comme un décalque c'est les pays de
l'est et les pays de vin au village près
au village près les pays devint vote à
gauche et les pays de l'est vote à
droite mais à un kilomètre près
je pense que ça a quelque chose à voir
avec eux 1 vous avez une carte
alors il ya une exception que je vous
dirai dans un astral mais en tout cas
chez nous dans le sud ouest c'est c'est
frappant le les pays de l'est pays de
vin les pays producteurs de lait alors
c'est parce qu'il ya quelque chose qui
est une entorse ce que la religion
n'empêchait pas la consommation
excessive de 20 ce qui pour environ
consommation excessive et un est un
paradis enfin quelque chose comme ça
mais c'est sûr que c'est sûr que ça
marche très bien une attestation
simplement témoignages sur ce que vous
avez dit sur le fait que que les choses
ne changent pas il ya une stabilité
électoral qui est quasi invariable au
travers du temps
j'avais fait à partir de cela le
logiciel dans les années
à la fin des années 90 qui permettait de
prévoir le résultat des élections en
fonction de l'étiage de chacun des
partis dans chaque circonscription
et à partir des sondages et j'avais
essayé d'empêcher alain juppé
d'accepter la dissolution de 97 parce
que c'était absolument invariable je
crois que j'avais trouvé le résultat à 5
sièges près tout bouge en même temps les
données
les données
l'est c'est à dire si vous avez à une
gauche très haute elle sera extrêmement
haute dans les pays qui lui sont
favorables
et à ses hôtes dans les pays qui ne lui
sont pas tous tout bouge comme un bateau
augmente avec la marée est donc eu le le
hasard ou l'aléa est extrêmement faible
peut-être moins de 5% lié à des
personnalités on s'aperçoit que tout le
monde bouge en en même temps ça rend
très humble ce jeu moi je suis l'élu de
la première circonscription démocrate
chrétienne de france en 1924 donc c'est
très bizarre mais c'est comme ça ça ça
bouge en même temps et enfin dernier
point je suis né dans un village très à
gauche
dans les pyrénées atlantiques
alors c'est des petites zones où on
croyait au je croyais qu'il était très à
gauche parce qu'il y avait beaucoup de
syndicalistes pour une grande usine
métallurgique à côté
et je me suis aperçu que c'est le
premier village qui avait saisi les
biens du clergé au moment de la
révolution dans le département et
pourtant les métallurgistes n'était pas
là les syndicalistes étaient minés ni à
naître et pourtant c'est un peu comme si
c'est pas quoi théorie des climats
dirait notre ami monter ce que je ne
sais pas mais en tout cas c'était déjà
le cas en 1780 voilà alors je vous
remercie parce que c'est tout à fait
dans la ligne
mais y'a pas il ya deux exceptions et
puis je reviendrai sur les curés joueurs
il ya deux eia
ya une carte dans la place où justement
j'ai mis la proportion j'ai pas mis le
lait mais j'ai mis des vaches laitières
donc et on a on est très proche sauf il
ya tout le limousin est hélas qui lui
est très à gauche donc
oui c'est alors on retrouve le mettais
ya c'est à dire le métayage qu'à
fabriquer d'ailleurs des familles
multiples on retrouve la même chose en
italie le communisme disons d'un en
emilie romagne et dans la région de
florence c'est lié à
ce régime de métayage ce qu'était un
régime très pauvres mais il ya quand
même une exception qui très souvent j'ai
été amené à perdre et
de la cartographie électorale au
lendemain des élections donc justement
cette pensée pouvoir prévoir j'ai quand
même été presque toujours largement déçu
et
parce que des mouvements qui
apparaissent puis disparaissent quand
rang 80 il faut se souvenir qu'en 80 les
sondages privés du samedi
avant le
premier tour la présidentielle donnaient
le pca 19% et il a été à 14 5% ouais
c'était le point alors bien sûr il a
baissé au même endroit où étaient mes
mais ça a été c'était centrale parce
qu'à ce moment là le ps n'apparaissait
plus comme
voilà ils sont homogènes absolument qu
est la vie votre comparaison de l'eau je
prends
et localement si on prends moi je suis
je connais plus la bretagne que
le sud ouest mais vous avez une petite
zone ont ainsi on avait regardé la carte
plus attentivement qui est une zone qui
s'appelle le aile droite qui est à
cheval sur les côtes d'armor et le
finistère où les curés était joueur ou
le charles tillon était originaire de là
le parti communiste reste très implanté
et d'ailleurs les bonnets rouges sont là
callac et l'épicentre de cette zone et à
mes amis médiéviste m'a montré que c'est
pas l'argile mais que au
au
xiième et xiiième siècle avec les
régimes de défrichage monastique qui a
eu une institution tout à fait
particulière de village collective qui
s'appelle la keven et quand on regarde
on a la carte de ces villages au 12e
siècle
entre 12e et 13e siècles on a une partie
de leur couple l'actuelle région qui est
de gauche qui est de curé géreur donc au
fond la dent dans cette partie de la
bretagne le parti communiste existait au
12e siècle quoi voilà
monsieur n'ont
justement pas en voyant vos cartes
j'avais une réflexion sur les
départements qui font l'objet d'un débat
actuel évidemment sur la question
territoriale et j'ai eu l'impression que
la sauvegarde du département aujourd'hui
à la lumière de aux cartes sert
davantage à donner l'illusion qu'on va
faire survivre des villes moyennes plus
que sauver rythme en territoire rural
vieillissant appauvri isolé est ce que
c'est une impression partagée à sachant
que les situations tout le monde
diverses sur le territoire oui c'est
sais pas c'est une interprétation
possible - fond mon imposition était
plutôt de dire si on revoit la
répartition des compétences il me semble
que la compétence sociale qui est déjà
d'ailleurs la compétence du département
la meilleure échelle c'est le
département parce que c'est justement là
où vous avez la plus grande diversité
sociale du fait de la présence de ces
villes moyennes qui se porte pas trop
mal comme vous l'avez vu sur les cartes
et puis de ses frontières qui au
contraire se porte le
nom le plus mal mais là ces présumés de
comment le partage s'effectuera au
niveau du département mais il ya là une
réalité si on t'aime de mixité sociale a
été très utilisé bas l'az le zonage qui
réalise la meilleure mixité sociale
c'est le département en france il n'y a
pas de doute là dessus c'est pas du tout
la région inversement le département en
terme de structures économiques
n'apparaissent n'apparaît presque jamais
d'ailleurs les régions della dès la 4e
république ou même d'ailleurs il ya des
textes de
des années 1918 et 1919 120 qui déjà
demandent la création de régions pour
des raisons d'échelle économique je
crois que au fond différentes échelles
et l'idée qui a été de on va supprimer
le département où on va souder les
régions les fusionner pourquoi ça dépend
de quel est le principe qu'on retient à
quoi ça sert absolument c'est hier qu'on
dise d'abord voilà à quoi à quoi ça sert
et on n'a pas encore dit alors peut-être
6,6 après avoir réparti des compétences
on s'aperçoit qu'il n'a presque plus au
niveau département ou des communes ou
les intercommunalités
on dira bomba autant les supprimer mais
jusqu'à preuve du contraire ça n'a pas
encore
et
des idées ni faits ni proposé
non là je pense pourrais m'étendre
longuement sur cette histoire de fusion
des régions mais
merci ça pète ça a permis de faire le
lien justement
ça cette réforme la territoriale au
excusez moi je voulais simplement savoir
si est ce que est ce qu'on vous avait
est-ce que vous avez été approché est ce
que votre expertise a été demandée par
qui que ce soit dans l'administration au
gouvernement par les députés qui sont en
train de voter sa loi c'est la première
question est la deuxième est la deuxième
question c'est est-ce que vous quelle
quelle idée pourriez vous avoir des
conséquences éventuelles parce que pour
imaginer qu'une réforme permettrait de
guérir de certaines erreurs du passé on
s'aperçoit que vous êtes faire d'autres
erreurs est ce que vous voyez vous des
conséquences éventuelles de la réforme
telle qu'elle va être par apparemment
voter alors sur le fait d'être consultés
en plus ça il se trouve que
pendant une dizaine d'années j'ai animé
un groupe de prospective à la datar et
j'ai même finalement présider le conseil
scientifique de la datar donc j'avais un
petit peu de bouteille sur la question
bien sûr non je n'ai pas été consulté
mais je suis pas le seul la datar a été
refondée sous le commissariat général à
l'égalité des territoires en février
dernier il se trouve que j'étais dans
une réunion avec des responsables de les
responsables de la datar qui exposait
qu'elle serait un découpage aurait
demandé est ce que
il avait été approché comme vous avez
posé comme question et ils ont pas
répondu ils ont dit que bon voilà le
voyez est finalement j'étais avec à la
roue c'est qui qui préside l'association
des régions de france qui a reposé la
question dit elle dit m et ils ont dit
non non on n'a eu aucune commande donc
dans le même homme on fondait une
refonte est une administration de deux
cas à près de 200 personnes qui est
compétente je trouve les publications
sont souvent très bonne on a n'ont pas
été consultés alain rousset aussi nous a
dit dans une petite réunion
ils étaient étonnés du chiffre de
d'ailleurs tout le monde de 12,5
milliards à 25 milliards d'économies que
vous avez vu alors il a il a dit qu'il a
approché comme une abeille savait pas
d'où sortait ce chiffre il a approché du
président quand même l'association des
régions de france en lui aussi on aurait
pu lui demander son avis et il a
approché la direction du budget il a
rencontré le directeur du budget et le
directeur du budget c'est lui qui nous
le c'est alain rousset crédit n'a dit a
répondu nos services sont à la recherche
de l'origine de ce chiffre donc
quiconque donc et vous vous connaissez
l'origine du chiffre maintenant si vous
lisez le canard enchaîné l'origine du
chiffre a été donné par le canard
enchaîné et le ministre vallini ne l'a
pas contredit ces il ya 500 milliards
qui sont attribuées aux collectivités
locales chaque année et il était dit que
quand on fait une réforme de structure
ont gagné entre 2 5% et 5% d'habitude
d'où sort ce pourcentage c'est comme un
homme sur quatre meurent de faim et
d'habitude donc ces 12,5 ses 2,5 pour
cent de 500 milliards et 25 milliards
c'est 5% de 500 mineurs donc voilà c'est
dire d'ailleurs on pourrait alléger le
nombre de fonctionnaires si on peut
faire des calculs aussi facilement sur
l'utilité des des réformes donc voilà en
ce qui concerne sert alors est-ce qu'on
ne gagnera non alors là c'est une autre
une autre histoire et là j'ai répondu et
j'ai à nouveau l'association des régions
de france a publié a publié un
je fais une microscopique études
maîtresse d'une idée très simple c'était
l'argument qui avait été défendu par le
président de la république était il
fallait des régions de taille européenne
1 et 2 à alès ça permettrait de booster
leur dynamisme et 3 les économies on
vient d'en parler mais je vais les
rameaux les régions de taille européenne
j'ai simplement pris les
länder allemands les länder allemands
sont beaucoup plus variables de taille
que les que les régions françaises on
quand on calcule la variabilité d'un
d'une distribution il ya un indice que
pénalise de jénine indice de gini de
variabilité airs et les länder allemands
est deux fois plus important que
l''indice gini des régions actuellement
les 13 régions actuellement proposé donc
l'idée qui a une taille européenne n'a
pas de sens d'ailleurs les cantons
suisses ne sont pas de taille européenne
les provinces italiennes etc on peut
aller là ça là bas oui de le alors
second point est ce que ça donne du
dynamisme économique
alors c'était très simple j'ai regardé
le pib par habitant des länder
ce qui était corrélée à la taille des
länder la corrélation est nul est ce que
la croissance économique des länder au
cours des dix dernières années est elle
liée à leur taille corrélation nul donc
c'est bien sûr que c'est plus compliqué
l'économie c'est des questions de
cohérence des questions de structures
des questions de projets ça se saurait
si ces dix suffisait d'être grand et à
la limite si c'est vraiment la taille
qui compte y'a qu'à supprimer toutes les
régions et tous faire à paris c'est là
qu'on gagnera le plus d'argent rasé
ridley prolonger deux côtés de la
frontière et je pensais en parlant de
métropole à lille où on a l'impression
que ce n'est qu'un petit bout et que
l'essentiel se passe de l'autre côté s
contre eux ferait les mêmes observations
ou est ce que vous auriez eu des
difficultés
liées à des problèmes d'harmonisation
statistiques c'est le premier point le
deuxième point sur les inégalités on
vous calez plus des inégalités de
revenus qu'est ce que donnerait des
cartes avec des inégalités de patrimoine
et si on croisait les deux on peut
penser qu'il ya des zones où on a des
revenus faibles patrimoine faible et
puis on voit en termes politiques donc
des personnes aidées des zones avec
patrimoine élevé revenu élevé et où ça
se corse ce serait des zones avec
patrimoine faibles revenus élevés et l'
inverse
et des conclusions justement sur les
modes de correction des inégalités
mais peut-être que sur les patrimoines
aussi vous a eu des difficultés pour
avoir des données dans toutes les zones
oui là sur ce dernier point c'est la
seule chose qu'on est celle isf et
encore on a une échelle très large et
liez f c'est un tout petit bout du du
patrimoine donc on on a une enquête
patrimoine de l'insee qui est fait
régulièrement mais c'est une enquête
donc on ne peut absolument pas
distinguer pour les régions ce serait
très important et je dois dire que ces
choses-là sont possibles dans les pays
autour de nous c'est pas il ya une sorte
de pudibonderie française camp sur la
question des revenus et des patrimoines
5 et quittent presque unique au monde
peut avoir je peux avoir
sur cette demande j'ai un cd rom de des
revenus des mexicains avec tout le
détail de leur profession tous et liés
au recensement même chose aux états unis
dans le recensement le revenu fait
partie des questions et vérifier avec
les données fiscales donc là là il ya un
problème pour la france qui est quand
même assez difficile
d'autant que les données existent au
ministère des finances il ya un certain
nombre d'études en plein travail
remarquable qui a été fait pour
redéfinir les zones urbaines sensibles
les zones d'éducation prioritaire et
cetera s'est basé sur des données
fiscales qui est par car et 200 mètres
sur 200 m en france donc on a toutes les
données mais elles sont pas communiqués
elle reste dans le bunker de
da bercy alors prolonger les cartes
j'avais c'est très difficile c'est
j'avais à une époque j'ai fait j'ai
publié d'ailleurs un hymne là dessus
j'ai simplement cherché à
prolonger des cartes démographique donc
voir le
comment à l'échelle de l'union europe à
l'époque c'était pas toute l'union
européenne n'ont encore
mais comment et comment la population
s'accroît sec quels étaient les densités
un niveau très fin il ya des très grande
continuité bien sûr c'est très
intéressant mais au delà déjà là c'était
très difficile parce que il faut pouvoir
disposer de deux communes pour et donc
les pays kurde est trop grosse commune
on voit pas très bien mais ton le
danemark où il ya je crois une et reste
que 80 communes dans le danemark et qui
ne publient pas des données plus fine et
duriez des pays comme l'irlande on
imagine qu on al un peu partout des
systèmes voisins ou analogue mais c'est
pas la même chose en irlande l'idée de
communes est totalement absente il
raisonne en termes de comptes et donc
j'avais utilisé des données qui était le
nombre de personnes dans les dents
dans les moments durs dans les lieux où
on faisait des scrutins électoraux
autant les donc dans les bureaux de vote
voilà j'avais les données des du nombre
d'inscrits dans le bureau de vote qui
était le seul moyen d'approcher la
population hyland donc quand on suit on
s'aventure sur des questions comme par
exemple les cadres le saas est
pratiquement impossible de recoller les
cartes en même temps j'ai des collègues
qui ont font des travaux analogues
notamment en allemagne et en italie et
les résultats sont très voisins ils sont
très voisins à la fois l'allemagne c'est
moins clair pour le lait la
régionalisation parce qu'à la coupure
est ouest qui subsistent encore en
grande partie mais en italie c'est bien
sûr très très clair les régions riches
et les régions pauvres là on n'est pas
du tout justement
une une exception dans ce que je vous ai
montré des différences régionales ce qui
est plutôt préoccupant c'est qu'elle
augmente en france donc qu'elle nous met
un peu au niveau de ce qui se passe dans
des pays voisins entre la flandre et et
la vallonie ou bien entre l'as que toute
la toux nord de l'italie et puis le sud
et les îles
pour faire vite je voudrais apporter un
témoignage et poser de questions
premiers témoignages à quoi ça sert
alors je fais référence un peu à mon
expérience au crédoc
nous avons tu t'en souviens évidemment
tout c'est toutes ces techniques de
cartographie traitements donnés sont
comme encore rendue possible par les
progrès des calculateurs et de
l'ordinateur et donc au début des années
80 le credoc avec nicole tabac avaient
commencé à faire c'était ces traitements
l'a simplement nous nous traitions
plutôt enfin elle traitait plutôt en
train fera par rapport à ce que toi tu
fais et
on avait en particulier vu et je crois
que toujours être le cas que là où il ya
une évolution qui est très très forte
c'est dans
les habitats et la façon dont les gens
se déplacent à l'intérieur même des
quartiers ou d'une commune à l'autre
c'est à dire que pour faire simple
l'accession à la propriété
la voiture et
les promoteurs ont fabriqué à
l'intérieur de deux catégories
extrêmement fine de territoire des
vitres véritable ségrégation d'un
quartier à l'autre on a vu des
variations très fort mais ce que je
voulais dire c'était le témoignage que
je voulais apporter c'est que moi m'a
beaucoup frappé c'est que s'il ya des
gens qui sont très intéressés par ce
type de carte ce sont les entreprises
les entreprises que de commerce en
particulier parce que c'est très
important pour l'immobilier commercial
de savoir où on va implanter et par
contre effectivement
mobilisés
le politique sur ce type de données je
sais pas pourquoi ça n'enclenche pas
mais finalement c'est pas spécifiques à
ce type de questions c'est vrai sur
pleins pleins d'autres domaines pour
prendre un exemple qui n'a strictement
rien à voir moi j'ai connu je sais pas
combien de dizaines de plans de réforme
de la sécurité sociale où ça se termine
toujours dans un cabinet ministériel sur
des coins des enveloppes en et faisant
peu appel aux travaux scientifiques non
j'avais deux questions pour les vite
première question il me semble que par
rapport à des travaux 10 à 30 ans il me
semble que dans la balance entre les
structures familiales et la religion la
religion
à remonter il me semble que tu as tu es
d'accord avec moi il me semble que ya
trente ans c'était un peu
l'idée dominante c'était quand même les
structurations familiale alors je sais
pas si je te laisserais nous expliquer
pourquoi tu as de jeu là je te
laisserais l'a dit alors mais justement
sur cette question là il ya un vieux
monsieur qui était un sociologue de la
religion qui est mort il ya 15 jours
s'est plaint emile poulat qui m'aura 93
ans et qui a été dans les quatre ou cinq
sociologue majeur du fait religieux des
50 dernières années je m'arrête au
cinquante dernières années et la laïcité
oui mais je le dirai plus de baubérot
que de que deux pour la poule a quand
même été beaucoup dans le catholicisme
mais je pose ma question poulat avait
avait une thèse qui était sac était sa
thèse qui était le triangle de poule
dans lequel il expliquait les
catholiques en france depuis d'ailleurs
léon xiii et la fin du 19ème sont en
fait à égale distance du libéralisme et
du socialisme et il ya un intégral isme
catholique qui est de refuser les deux
catégories que sont le libéralisme et le
socialisme et je trouvais que ses thèses
abouti c'est assez assez bien d'ailleurs
une certaine conception du centre qui
est un centre dans ses racines
chrétiennes qui ne veut pas se donner à
un camp ou à l'autre est qui et qui
bascule et je je je voulais évoluer ça
parce que dans les cartes que tu nous a
montré la bretagne apparaît cohérent on
est là par la bretagne ne bouge pas or
on avait dit
dans les années mitterrand que l'arrivée
de mitterrand savait était le
basculement à gauche chez les
socialistes des bretons de l'ouest etc
alors comment est-ce que tu conjuguent
dans l'analyse c'est intéressant que ça
ne bouge pas cette idée un peu de tout
là sur le triangle du catholicisme et
puis le basculement il fait alors
c'était juste pour faire un peu l'avocat
du diable parce que moi j'ai regardé
quand même attentivement les résultats
des dernières européennes et il me
semble quand même que dans la montée du
front national et dans la
déstructuration des socialistes du vote
socialiste il ya une différence pour
faire simple entre celui qui est
extrêmement créé depuis très longtemps
qu'elle sud ouest il ya par exemple
beaucoup beaucoup résisté et celui
d'autres types de régions où ça c'est
pratiquement complètement effondré c'est
à dire et est ce que est ce qu'on peut
contrôler tout ce que tu nous dis par un
autre indicateur qui est le degré
d'intransigeance dans les dindes dans
l'est dans les façons de penser dans les
façons de s'exprimer et qui résistera
d'ailleurs se renvoient aussi les
travaux de sociologie qui existeraient
d'autant plus que les gens sont sur du
dur c'est à dire dans le sud-ouest dans
alors de des mines de carmaux jusqu'à
emmanuelli dans les landes comment se
fait-il que quand tu regardes les
européennes vote socialiste a beaucoup
résisté dans ce coin là alors que dans
d'autres régions je pense en particulier
au nord il s'est totalement totalement
effondré et là le le boulevard pour
marine le pen a été extrêmement
important
aussi bien sûr que vous avez vous ce que
je cherche c'est à avoir une vue
d'ensemble à partir de deux phénomènes
locaux donc bien entendu
mes cartes sons
ne serait ce que par le lissage comme
des différences locales qui sont très
nombreuses c'est il faudrait imaginer
j'avais cherché à faire un travail à une
époque là dessus il faut imaginer ces
différences comme c'est une théorie
mathématique et celle des fractales
c'est à dire ce que chaque fois que vous
passez un niveau plus faible vous
retrouver de la différence air et ainsi
de suite et prenez par exemple un
exemple très simple des différences de
fécondité en france quand vous les
prenez elle s'exile au niveau des
régions puis des départements puis à des
niveaux encore plus fatiguées elles
existent à l'intérieur d'un immeuble il
ya des familles de six enfants puis des
familles sans enfant ou avec un enfant
donc à toutes les échelles mais il ya un
point commun comme que vous c'est celui
là que je fais apparaître mais c'est une
petite part de la variabilité malgré
tout heureusement d'ailleurs la barbe y
était la variabilité individuelle reste
très forte sur les entreprises oui c'est
tout à fait juste mais alors il ya un pc
massivement fesses et les états unis
mais ils ont tout une discipline
s'appelle des mots metrics et il utilise
les données de recensement pour toutes
sortes de bus commerciaux c'est assez
curieux qu'en france on le fasse
relativement
relativement peu et oui c'est ça c'est
oui c'est mais c'est pas pratique et ya
des grosses entreprises aux états unis
alors qu'en france sur alors sur le
sur l'ouest il se trouve que j'ai
travaillé un niveau plus fin sur l'ouest
récemment nettement je fais un petit
atlas des pays de la loire qui ont
failli d'ailleurs disparaître l atlas
avec lui mais heureusement les pays de
la loire sont restées intactes donc mon
atlas été publiés et c'est remarquable
de voir qu effectivement le l'ouest a
assez largement dans les années récentes
basculer vers la gauche mais comme tu le
sais le vote de votre modèle vote
démocrate chrétien est resté plutôt
améliorée il n'est pas il n'a pas du
tout pattes il n'y a pas eu un
reversement de lin de l'un à l'autre oui
absolument si tu es là il ya toute une
structure à comprendre qui est
intéressante sur le fn là il faut bien
voir que ce qui se passe au fn et mais
vous en avez eu au fond un avant goût
dans ce que j'ai montré c'est un
basculement c c'est-à-dire il ya ni à un
fn qui est celui du père qui est un fn
xénophobes y libéral qui a une certaine
géographie et cette géographie ayant fn
de la fille qui est fille et étatiques
et elle s'adresse aux marginaux gens qui
sont
plutôt
exclu disons qu'ils ne l'ont pas accès
entièrement à
à l'espace public ou bien où et c'est
donc ces deux de stratégies très
différentes qui se marquent très
simplement et on avait donné les
chiffres dans le mystère français on a
calculé la corrélation entre le vote le
pen est la proportion de maghrébins par
département on l'a fait ça de 1984 à
2012 en 1984 la corrélation lé
2.82 ça veut dire c'est énorme si vous
voulez plus forte corrélation c1 la plus
faible c'est moins 1 donc c'est très
important et ça baisse continûment sa
baisse nettement la part d'un degré est
déjà nettement plus basse qui donne déjà
le clé du changement de stratégie et
quand on arrive en 2012 la corrélation
est devenu nul en effet pu ça et quand
on regarde ce qu'il ya une autre carte
qui est la progression la comparaison
entre 2002 et 2012 pour le premier tour
de jean-marie le pen et de sa fille et
là la comparaison est à la fois
éloquente et un peu inquiétante on voit
que contrairement à un fond une image
qu'on a justement qui date un peu ce
front national il a beaucoup perdu c'est
la même pratiquement le même score total
1 milliard marine le pen a fait 1 % de
moins ou un demi pour cent de moins que
son père plus mégret en 2002 aussi pour
dire quand on dit jia grand péril et
touba ils sont ils sont aussi restées
étales pendant un très long temps fort
n'est pas obligé de de s'effrayer même
du score des européennes
et quand on regarde là là où il a perdu
beaucoup de voix ou du moins beaucoup de
pourcentage c'est l'alsace c'est toute
la région rhône alpes qui n'est plus du
tout un bastion du fn et c'est une
partie notamment la partie côtière
de provence côte d'azur la partie qui va
vers nice notamment et donc c'est des
régions qui se porte plutôt bien
d'ailleurs et inversement il ya une
progression est tout à fait raison mais
la progression très forte c'est vers le
limousin c'est vers
disons la partie le sud de la normandie
c'est sur les franges et quand on
regarde dans le détail c'est cette fois
là une progression des communes les plus
dans les communes les plus rurales où le
score jérôme fourquet dont j'ai parlé
tout à l'heure à faire un tout petit
travail mais très intéressant il a
regardé pour la loire atlantique la
croissance du vote front national
et il avait une carte en peau de léopard
dont qu'il comprenait pas et quelqu'un
lui a dit mais il suffit de tracer les
routes nationales et c'est des points
qui sont loin des cds communes qui sont
loin des quelques routes nationales donc
il ya vraiment un phénomène
particulier de deux au fond de vote de
personnes qui sont à l'écart qui sont et
qui sont allés car au fond bien sûr
socialement souvent mais peut-être
surtout aussi géographiquement mais les
deux où l'avez vu dans mes cartes
commence hélas à se recouvrir
encontre ne sont pas les idées du front
national qui se répandent c'est les gens
qui vont au fond ne sied à notre
écoute et merci encore à hervé le bras
je vous donne rendez vous le 21 janvier
ceux qui ont des questions rentrée
peuvent les lui poser maintenant mai
tiens vraiment à ce que nos rêves soient
respectés
et vous avez tous évidemment dans
l'atlas des inégalités chez autrement